different
what extent uh to what extent does your
Christianity or religious face faith
play into your views on relationships
and everything
I think I'm not religious you don't no I
mean I had periods I go in and out I
grew up Catholic so I did 12 Years at
Catholic school and then I joined a
Christian church right after
right yeah right after college and I
like did Bible study a lot for like two
years but I got a lot of things about
the church that just like bothers me I
feel like feminism has infiltrated the
church so I have like my thoughts on
church I wouldn't say really I haven't
been to church in like 20 years but is
that real like the average Church like
has like way more Progressive stuff
going on
um I would say that they don't
be Flags in church right like what
but if I mean let's be real like
religion is kind of on the way out
churches like religions becoming less
and less popular I feel like they
probably have to like lean into that if
they want to continue to exist well
that's the thing like they have to cater
to women because women are the primary
market for church I think the church
leaves women single because when I was
in the church like when I was super into
it right after college they were like
you can only date in your church and I
was just like looking around I'm like
what on Earth what the [__] that's not
like an average rule that you have to
date within the church right typically
like they have to be that's why they
have the term equally yolked equally
young yeah yeah so I mean or they'll say
you can you can date other Christian
churches but the other problem is they
all are like 70 women roughly right if
you look at like the younger people that
are in the church they're mostly women
and the guys are like kind of simpy like
a bit so like I've heard guys say like
the girls in church are worse than the
girls outside of church like I would
like to think that I'm respectful of
everybody's religious beliefs and [__]
but if you're a young dude and you're
spending a lot of time in church
I mean well it's just well you really
need this much [__] help to get
through the day like I just don't
understand I mean I just think they
don't
like I respect people that are religious
and that are really religious and
um I feel like I could like I could be
really really just I just haven't really
found like the right
place maybe like I just feel like
feminism has infiltrated the church and
like they encourage men to take unfair
deals because it's like like okay when I
went was in Catholic School I've always
been me right just opinionated just like
you know and they would always have
these Chastity speakers which are
basically like people that come to the
church or the school and they'll say
like don't have sex until you're married
and it's always like a ran through girl
with the guy that like waited and that's
kind of an unfair deal because the guy
has to wait to give his commitment to a
girl that's already had sex so it's like
it's it's like what what does he get out
of the deal do you actually think that a
guy or a guy or a girl waiting until
they're married to have sex is a good
idea
um I think they're both virgins yeah I
mean that's what
um I can't name like the study off the
top of my head but if you look at body
count when it comes to girls like the
fewer Partners they have the more likely
they are to be happy after a certain
amount of time it's like after 10 years
but the best outcomes are when both of
them are virgins I feel like you need to
have sex to understand if you have good
sexual chemistry how would you know
by having sex no but I'm saying if
you're both virgins how would you know I
know but then like you're just sort of I
mean I think a woman getting into a
relationship a serious relationship as
serious as marriage without having a a
wide variety of experiences you're just
kind of asking you're creating a tick
and Time Bomb where she's gonna at some
point wanna know what the [__] else is
going on in life and I've seen this over
and over with people that I knew who got
married when they were young when they
were virgins and it's just inevitably
like one or both people ends up Wilding
out or wanting to have some more
experiences for me the reason why I'm
able to be so comfortable and secure in
my relationship is the fact that I've
[__] hundreds of people and I know
exactly what's out there and I don't
feel tempted by any of it yeah that is a
dynamic um Rolo has talked about that
where basically like if the girl gets
too young like it's basically like The
Virgins of today aren't the virgins of
yesterday because the virgins of today
still have social media and can like
hear things and see things that feel
like they're missing out
um so yeah I would say that happens like
I can't think of a more full of plan for
me being miserable than me like valuing
like you know innocence so much that I
end up wiping up somewhat like 19 20
year old virgin who doesn't know
anything about life who's gonna [__]
be looking at everything else out there
as like so tantalizing and interesting
it's like I I feel way more comfortable
with somebody who's been around the
block that actually like knows what's
out there
of the myth
I need a girls put some drugs up her
nose man
you know I do think like attracts
tracks so you know
yeah that's fine but okay here's the
thing my level of jealousy with my girl
is almost like non-existent like there's
almost nothing that she could do that
would like trigger my brain to be like
pissed off because we just have that
kind of connection and I know that she's
been around rappers and she's been to
the clubs and she's like done all this
like [__] that I've also done and I know
that she doesn't feel tempted by that
but I've also I've been in relationships
with girls who like are in the club with
you and then they're looking at the
section with the rich dudes who got
hella bottles and everything and like
yeah they're with you but you could kind
of tell that they're looking at those
dudes like if it was easy they would
probably just go and be with those dudes
like if they could sort of like bow out
without you knowing and go do that they
would be happy to do that with my girl I
don't have that feeling I actually like
don't think that she's tantalized by the
bottles in the in the club so I don't
know I feel like a lot of girls like
that that would be my main concern if I
was dating somebody very young or very
like inexperienced I don't I don't think
there's one way to do it you know what I
mean like I think whatever works for
someone works for them but I mean I
think by and large men prefer girls that
are more pure in general usually guys
want a girl that slept with less gut
less like Partners than they have
typically right no I can't understand
why but my brother's kind of a [__]
a [__] yeah really well probably not
compared to you he's probably an angel
compared to you no offense like
um but he like he's dating a girl that's
a virgin like yeah so well I don't think
she's even me I feel like if you're that
[__] how do you even meet a virgin I
don't know it's weird my brothers find
like all the girls that the red like
guys in the red pill like kind of say
that they want my brothers they're not
red pill at all they just are they've
never really had trouble with girls they
just like find them like my my other
brother is dating a girl that went to
culinary school for fun just to like
cook for him he didn't even ask he
didn't care right he was like oh it's
nice sweetie and these guys can barely
get their girls to cook for them at all
right culinary school my other brother
is dating a virgin he didn't even he
wasn't even really looking for one he
just like found her but how important do
you think that is how's your cooking
how's it I'm a good cook okay okay I
will say I've been learning so
um recently I've been learning to make a
cake from scratch I've just learned
jollof rice the other day so I I would
say one to ten I'm like a six I'll give
myself a six because me and my uh group
chat with like 20 dudes were all having
this conversation this morning because
there's this porn star girl I know and
she posts on her story like cooking like
tons of [__] she cooked this whole big
[__] feast and the caption was like
you know this is my love language or
whatever for her boyfriend or whatever
and I sent it to the group chat and I
was like being honest like how
attractive do you find this girl being
able to cook because for me in my head
and now this is all like hypothetical
because obviously I'm not gonna go
[__] holler at this chick but
the cooking thing actually like really
kind of in my brain soothes some of my
concern that she might be a psychopath
like the cooking thing just knowing that
she could like be focused on her
domestic duties in the crib for like six
hours to cook this I mean I know a lot
of chicks who don't have that in them
that realistically they're so out of
control that they're gonna go find
cocaine instead of within that six hour
period
cocaine
you live in [__] London you're acting
like you're like totally naive to Coke
everyone in England is doing ketamine
and cocaine right now
99 of the population the queen even my
experience
my experience with Coke in life one time
on New Year's when I was 21. oh let's go
here we go someone offered me Coke at a
bar and I was like what's what
um I also had friends in Chicago that
worked in finance that I noted Coke a
lot that's all I know about Coke so
you're like one time someone offered it
to me I didn't even do it just got
offered no well this was shocking to me
yeah
but you live in England everybody does
coke in England like it's bad okay okay
now maybe your friends do code I'm not
everybody I ever met out there okay
um but I play with like I know athletes
mostly so I think a drug tester you get
drug tested no you should definitely do
Coke
no we did in college but they're like
drugs just I don't I don't know I've
never asked there might be people that
do it I just don't think like they would
offer it to me anyway because I don't
even I don't even really drink so it's
like right you're gonna offer me like
you can't get me to take a shot but
you're gonna give me Coke what's your
observation oh you don't even drink yeah
that's probably a good sign well I
decided I'm gonna do it once a year
drink yeah once a year well just enough
to remind yourself how much you hate it
yeah because I hate it like if I did it
once a year it would be a great reminder
of like oh that's why you don't like
that yeah no I I used to drink but I
stopped a couple years years ago right
but then I was like maybe I'll do it
once a year we'll see I haven't decided
I've been going back and forth on this
my thing is like I I stopped like
getting drunk maybe like four or five
years ago but I'll still have like a
drink yeah or a glass of wine that's
fine yeah maybe maybe that could be like
my once a year if you can do it on no
jump as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible